or get to show on the Harriet I got rich
a false arrest
yeah Danny DeVito Kevin Hart Tiffany
Haddish you same old Colin Farrell David
Schwimmer but it Kevin Smith Fred Daisy
Ridley Capaldi this is snack wars for
Lana hi bring on the snacks it's a call
to class I worked in the restaurant
industry for years and I had no idea
because I worked in shitholes it's like
a bush took a trial it is here the
testicle right okay let Julie dealers
yeah this is a British attempt at a
Philadelphia cheesesteak I'm gonna taste
it first and make sure they captured the
essence you should concede this one
right now jellied eels but it's pretty
esoteric yeah I mean that could be too
interesting for the American palate over
here that would lose in the ocean right
there are fish never swim faster sorry
what's this a Philadelphia Philadelphia
cheesesteak it's a burner [ __ ] is it
sort of kids food really for kids and
kids at heart
sadly we're gonna lose this one god I
have to tell you I mean I love peal I
love jelly the temperature could just
there is no friggin temperature whatever
become tasty right right at the point
where it turns from gas to plasma is
there a way you're supposed to eat it
yeah just watch out for the bone in the
middle here close-up so what is this
again tell me God with this is not jelly
Dale jellied eel
[Music]
Wow that's awful that's definitely an
acquired taste in the quadtest
there's no way you think jelly deal well
I'm sorry for sophistication
we've nicked this he's being paroled we
saw two different fights in okay but is
this the categorized as sophistication
okay what what is I mean okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna eat this now oh I don't know
what it is this is I trust you guys
right okay
we need to expand our horizons that's
not gonna work
and then Turtles of course then they're
Turtles I'm gonna go turtles for the win
here cuz I just gave me a Caterpie
smells like something that should hold
like massive amounts of industrial
equipment together and this this tastes
like nothing like a turtle but delicious
nonetheless what the hall I don't know
you guys have been talking to my family
or something because you're too poor to
bring the top two SoCo shrimp in the
shot so not good sunken yah-huh be
selfish your CEO Jim King job guns hot
Rubio does to come in fatigued
what is this is it like soda Joe Casey
I'm Ken
Oh No
I've gotta find some way to answer in
cano mind
c'mon is there any peanut butter in here
no no don't take that my way with this
later
definitely me let's get the snaps of a
gun schnell there we go boys fish cooler
now voice is that fish
oh yeah crank it open we've got pork
pies as well oh my god that's like
scallops and Bob it is listen I'm not
looking forward to this you turn it
upside down that's the last well I
reckon I've been sick like that
we take these away quick I can't get I
can't get it down oh yeah that was
genuinely that was horrific
well I've seen wow so now we're happy
what is this
I've never seen this we're not spying
with two Gs and States freaking cold
Craig soft drive
was it a sausage roll okay great
are you sure it's not plastic it's
rather hard hold on
it's a vegan sausage roll I haven't
tried this let's give it a shot
there we go all right five minutes to
live don't well that's pretty honorable
I wouldn't recommend eating it all the
time
it breaks Greg Koss control pretty good
oh wow
come on states bringing on the sausage
roll I'm ready to leave and go to grudge
yeah no means no quick absolutely a
question don't question yeah yeah
because she's smart
well you've taken the two best flavors
in the world peanut butter and chocolate
and getting them together so that's a
delight this is just one of the best
flavors in the world but it's looser
I'd say it has to be four I don't know
what either these things out I mean
that's looks like a big old and I tell
you what it feels like
I'll talk about the heads all right okay
we don't look like that and Scotland
they don't make that while more chili
like
[Music]
oh it's [ __ ] greasy as far my hands
go whistling which incidentally is also
what happened when I passed my port back
Paul supposed to be pink in the middle
it looks about pink then I've just took
quite a big bait over I mean I'm always
good at all for the penis shaped snacks
just a laugh I don't usually eat
anything because I'm too busy spewing up
so whatever I had the neighbour fall is
usually a good start and I'll probably
get a pizza or something and because my
mother's cooking
[ __ ] disgusts me actually watching
mum [ __ ] sort your show
alright I go first
this is a lemon to look like quality I
don't if I pick if you pick the next a
person up wait I'm going us a.m. you
wake it tastes like you can wash dishes
with it Twinkie was a safer bite I've
always had an awful straightaway when I
say frazzles I'm not even interested -
what's in that no these are amazing what
do I love about frazzle I piss all these
snacks on Oh shiny they make your
fingers and these your fingers are
glowing under these the best thing about
these as well you can lick your fingers
for I was after and you can still trim
flakes this - this to me is a prawn
cracker small progress Oh
authentic it on that yeah that's right
you know a Fresnel or there's some
appraisals all day long bought in the
sort of comes across the water
international friendship yeah I'm we're
for that yeah
sticking with a puzzle yeah shrimp legs
then that isn't intention goes what's in
there holy the hell is this taser oh
you've got to use the branch to piece of
white bread and some water
what do you put down a real party is
this Irish food again that's American
you can tag combos below blue he is
making I can't sit in a home in my
weight is very simple let's open this
one up with the Buffalo though be
classic cooked since night oh man look
at that look at that
he's only brought to the crew now you
guys have some all right everybody grab
it both snack wars here we go
good do it like they have to eat too you
know they're over there running the
equipment get out of here go on take and
they gotta clean up
that's the are you doing I'm already
over there are you eat yeah cuz we're
winning we make better stuff you have to
throw your [ __ ] away I just ate mine
what is that no because I'm telling
people I mean you can have a competition
without singing our National Anthem
oh say
I mean this was a fixed contest it was
this was a fixed contest it was very
clear I'm writing a letter it was one
like one of our elections in America
shame on you lad Bible came on you
[Music]